programming throwdown episode 59 deploying software take it away jason hey everyone i have some pretty cool news so i've done some digging into T-shirts. I found out something kind of interesting. So there's two ways to get T-shirts printed. The first way is ink printing. And that looks, you know, okay. Like, I don't really want to, like, bash it too much. But it's not what you expect.
Programming Throwdown 第59期，部署软件。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，我有个很酷的消息。我研究了一下T恤，发现了一些有趣的事情。印制T恤有两种方式。第一种是喷墨打印，看起来还行，你知道的，我不想太贬低它，但它确实达不到你的预期。
Like, when you see a T-shirt, like a professional t-shirt someone's wearing, this is not that. Like, this is just, like, it looks, like, kind of stained. Then they have screen printing, and that's, like, the real deal. So I found a place that will do screen printing, but the caveat is we have to put in our order in advance. So they just print it all. Like I said, they have to set up some equipment. They print it all and then they kind of tear down the equipment. It's not really like quite an on-demand thing. So I set up a straw poll. I'm going to post a straw poll in the show notes and also on Facebook, Google+, all of those social media channels. And go on the straw poll and vote your size.
就像你看到别人穿的专业T恤时，那不是喷墨印的。那种看起来有点像污渍。然后是丝网印刷，那才是真正的专业工艺。我找到了一家可以做丝网印刷的店，但前提是我们必须提前下单。他们必须安装设备，一次性印完，然后再拆卸设备。这并不是那种随需应变的服务。所以我建立了一个Straw Poll投票，我会把它放在节目说明里，也会发在Facebook、Google+等所有社交媒体渠道上。请去投票选出你的尺码。
If you want to buy two, vote twice. So I've set it up so that you can do that. And put in your votes, and then we will bulk order the T-shirts. And I'll try and figure out some way to get it to everyone. But put in the order now and then also send Patrick and I an email. So we have your email address. So you put in the order, like the vote. That way we kind of have an idea of how many people are interested and things like that.
如果你想买两件，就投两次票。我已经设置好了，你可以这样做。投完票后，我们会批量订购T恤。我会想办法把它们送到每个人手中。但请现在就下单，并给Patrick和我发封邮件，这样我们就有你的邮箱地址了。你下单投票后，我们就能知道有多少人感兴趣，诸如此类。
Also email us and let us know what size you want. That way we have a way of getting back to you. And yeah, let's make some awesome t-shirts. I'm really excited. The design looks awesome. And I think this is going to be pretty killer. So that's the intro. Let's do news and links. So my news item, first news item is Keras, and specifically it's Keras.js. So Keras is a neural net library. The idea is you have a neural network which is a sort of nonlinear composition of functions that's meant to sort of learn some mapping. So for example, let's say you have a bunch of weather data. You have the day of the year, like is it February 14th of whatever year, and what the weather is. And you want to build some model that says what tomorrow's weather is going to be. You could run it all through a
也请发邮件告诉我们你想要的尺码，这样我们才有办法联系你。好的，让我们制作一些很棒的T恤吧。我真的很兴奋，设计看起来太棒了，我觉得这会非常酷。这就是开场白，现在进入新闻和链接环节。我的第一条新闻是关于Keras，具体来说是Keras.js。Keras是一个神经网络库。它的理念是，神经网络是一种非线性函数组合，旨在学习某种映射。例如，假设你有一堆天气数据，包括日期（比如某年的2月14日）和当天的天气，你想建立一个模型来预测明天的天气。你可以把这些数据输入到
neural net, and it will approximate, it will kind of interpolate based on the averaging and all that, what the weather is going to be like. So neural nets are very, very popular for doing machine learning. Keras is a pretty cool library. The reason why I mentioned this is they made something called Keras JS, which is pretty cool. The idea is you can take a model that's trained. So you could take, you know, your weather model that you trained with Keras and you can actually run it in the browser. So someone can actually have your model running in their browser and play with the days and get different weather forecasts and things like that. So I thought, you know, especially for building tools and just for visualization, it's kind of kind of cool. So I guess to kind of elaborate more or whatever, because I don't I know a lot of people get a lot of people are curious
神经网络中，它会通过平均值等方法进行插值，从而近似得出明天的天气。所以神经网络在机器学习中非常非常流行。Keras是一个很酷的库。我提到这个是因为他们做了一个叫Keras.js的东西，非常酷。它的理念是，你可以拿一个已经训练好的模型，比如你用Keras训练的天气模型，直接在浏览器中运行。这样别人就可以在他们的浏览器中运行你的模型，调整日期，获取不同的天气预报等等。我觉得这对于构建工具和可视化来说非常酷。为了进一步阐述，因为我知道很多人对
about machine learning, but I don't always exactly understand how it is when you say they run the model. What you're saying is you've trained it previously in some other way, but they can actually take a given set of inputs and get the results without kind of training or changing the underlying model that's already been trained or the weights that have been given. Yeah, that's exactly right. And the reason why this is kind of really interesting and hard is they actually run it on your GPU. So, you know, these models, you know, obviously training it is very difficult, but even executing the model, if it's really big, like imagine if the model is doing some kind of crazy image processing where it's, you know, taking your face and like putting a dog face on it something, like overlaying a dog tongue on your face like what Snapchat does.
机器学习很好奇，但我并不总是完全理解当你说“运行模型”时是什么意思。你的意思是，你之前通过某种方式训练了它，但他们可以在不进行训练或改变底层已训练模型或权重的情况下，输入一组给定的数据并得到结果？是的，完全正确。之所以这很有趣且困难，是因为他们实际上是在你的GPU上运行它。你知道，这些模型，训练过程当然非常困难，但即使是执行模型，如果它很大，比如想象一下模型在做某种疯狂的图像处理，比如把你的脸换成狗脸，或者像Snapchat那样在你的脸上叠加一个狗舌头。
Those kind of models are really complicated. You can download a model which does that so you don't have to train it yourself. They've trained it on a bunch of people's faces. But even just running that model in the browser, it just would run way too slow unless it used your graphics card. And so I don't even know how they did this, but somehow I guess there's a JavaScript library for accessing your graphics card. Oh, it's probably WebGL, right? Well, it's open source, so we can look at the source and figure it out. That's right. So they're probably like, they probably
这类模型非常复杂。你可以下载一个能做到这一点的模型，这样就不必自己训练了。他们已经在很多人的脸上训练过它了。但即使只是在浏览器中运行该模型，如果不用显卡，速度也会慢得离谱。我甚至不知道他们是怎么做到的，但我想可能有一个JavaScript库可以访问你的显卡。哦，那可能是WebGL，对吧？嗯，它是开源的，所以我们可以查看源代码来弄清楚。没错，所以他们可能
did some crazy web gl hacking or something i have no idea how they did this but it's fascinating and uh they even have some sample models which is pretty cool there's a model that where you can draw on the screen and it'll tell you what number you drew like if you drew a three or a four um so yeah check it out if nothing else check it out as like a cool toy to play with um but if you're into doing machine learning uh check it out for realsies because it's pretty cool i should also say uh snapchat is probably not using a neural network model for or a machine learning model at all for applying a tongue to a face really yeah you have to detect your face
做了一些疯狂的WebGL黑客操作之类的，我不知道他们是怎么做到的，但这很迷人。而且他们甚至有一些示例模型，这很酷。有一个模型，你可以在屏幕上画画，它会告诉你画的是什么数字，比如是3还是4。所以，去看看吧，即使只是把它当作一个好玩的玩具。但如果你对机器学习感兴趣，一定要认真看看，因为它真的很酷。我还得说，Snapchat可能根本没有使用神经网络或机器学习模型来给脸部贴舌头。真的吗？你得先检测到脸部，
right so i well maybe but i mean you could do things like detect features of the face like through sift or some other kind of features and tracking and putting it on i mean do you think they're evaluating like they may have like a eye detector that is a model but you think they really have a apply tongue to face thing oh no no you're totally right so yeah they have like the neural net says an eyeball is here a nose is here and then from there they kind of guess or maybe they have a neural net that figures out where the corners of your mouth are or something yeah right or even just more traditional image processing for doing those things i mean i don't know what state of the art is or how well it works i've never used that feature to be fair yeah so so so people used to
对吧？嗯，也许吧，但我的意思是，你可以通过SIFT或其他特征检测和追踪来做到这一点。你觉得他们真的在评估……他们可能有一个眼睛检测器，那是一个模型，但你觉得他们真的有一个“给脸部贴舌头”的模型吗？哦不，你是对的。所以，是的，他们可能有神经网络来定位眼球、鼻子，然后从那里进行猜测，或者他们可能有一个神经网络来找出你嘴角的位置之类的。没错，或者甚至只是用更传统的图像处理来做这些事情。我不知道目前最先进的技术是什么，或者效果如何，老实说我从没用过那个功能。是的，所以人们过去
do a lot with like sift and these kind of like they're called unsupervised methods the idea is you know sift is just like it's a way to just say look this part of an image is interesting and someone has taken so many images um over such a long period of time that they have this kind of interesting detector um a lot of people are moving from that to neural nets where they um have labeled data and they say you know i want a corner of mouth detector um so that's kind of the state of the art you're right though. Snapchat could probably get away with just using SIFT. The accuracy would be like a little less, but it'd probably be fine for most things. I mean, most people are looking right at the camera.
经常使用SIFT之类的方法，它们被称为无监督方法。SIFT只是一种判断图像某部分是否有趣的方法。有人在很长一段时间内处理了如此多的图像，以至于他们有了这种有趣的检测器。很多人正在从那种方法转向神经网络，他们有标记过的数据，比如他们想要一个“嘴角检测器”。所以这算是目前最先进的技术。不过你是对的，Snapchat可能只用SIFT就能搞定。准确度可能会低一点，但对大多数情况来说可能足够了。毕竟，大多数人都是正对着摄像头。
Well, also, they need to be able to do it, you know, kind of they're probably willing to accept less accuracy for something that runs more quickly on a bunch of devices. Yeah, that's a good point. Yeah, great point. But those are the kinds of things you have to think about. There's some trade off there. Yeah, I mean, you know, in general, like neural nets are, I mean, they're super old, but they weren't that popular until maybe five years ago or something. And so, you know, now like phone companies are starting to catch up and things like that. But there's still a lot of, as Patrick said, a lot of devices where, you know, you could run SIFT pretty easily, but you can't run a neural net.
嗯，而且他们需要能够做到这一点，他们可能愿意为了在大量设备上运行得更快而牺牲一些准确性。是的，好观点。确实是好观点。但这些就是你必须考虑的事情，这里面存在权衡。是的，我的意思是，总的来说，神经网络非常古老，但在五年前左右才开始流行。所以，现在手机公司开始赶上来了。但正如Patrick所说，仍然有很多设备，你可以很容易地运行SIFT，但却无法运行神经网络。
So the next news article we have is called More Interesting Mazes. And it's on, I don't actually know how you would pronounce the name of this website, but it's been around forever, Gamasutra. I call it Gamas sutra but yeah you're probably right it could be yeah so this is you know you've probably seen them before if you've hung out anywhere i don't even know how far back they go but they run a lot of articles about technology behind making games game development uh they host like post-mortems for failed games and so there's an article i read a few days ago about generating interesting mazes and this is at first i thought it was going to be about you know the maze that
下一篇新闻文章叫《更有趣的迷宫》。它在……我其实不知道该怎么读这个网站的名字，但它已经存在很久了，Gamasutra。我叫它Gamasutra，但你是对的，可能是那样。所以，如果你在任何地方逛过，你可能以前见过他们。我甚至不知道他们存在多久了，但他们发布了很多关于游戏开发背后技术的文章，他们会举办失败游戏的“尸检”分析。所以我几天前读了一篇关于生成有趣迷宫的文章。起初我以为它是关于
you did when you were well maybe you still do them but where you have an entry point on one side and an exit point on another uh and you're trying to go through the maze but i guess it's all it's kind of just talking about more generally a maze being a mathematical term where there are rooms and walls and there is only a single path between any two rooms so kind of like doom like the levels and do exactly right so talking about like levels for a game although i mean you could have multiple paths there isn't anything wrong with that but if you restrict yourself to trying to have a unique path between two different points and then kind of going about how an algorithm would generate a maze and there's like a lot of naive ways of doing it but then if you kind of start adding coloring to the various you can think of
你小时候玩的那种迷宫，或者也许你现在还在玩，就是一端有入口，另一端有出口，你试图穿过迷宫。但我猜它是在更广泛地讨论迷宫，这是一个数学术语，指有房间和墙壁，且任意两个房间之间只有一条路径。就像《毁灭战士》的关卡一样。完全正确。所以是在讨论游戏关卡，尽管你可以有多条路径，那也没什么错。但如果你限制自己，试图在两点之间建立唯一路径，然后讨论算法如何生成迷宫。有很多天真的做法，但如果你开始给各种节点添加颜色，你可以把它想象成
it as like a grid into the various nodes on the grid adds different coloring and run the algorithm. You can kind of generate and it has a, if nothing else, you can just go through and look at all the pictures. They're kind of cool where they generate slanted mazes and, you know, circular mazes, recursive mazes,
一个网格，给网格上的各种节点添加不同的颜色并运行算法。你可以生成……如果没什么别的，你至少可以浏览并查看所有图片。它们很酷，比如生成倾斜的迷宫、圆形迷宫、递归迷宫，
and just talking about all the different ways to generate. And I, you know, it doesn't kind of call it out, but this is very similar to kind of procedurally generated, or i feel like this is sort of similar where you're kind of taking a notion or description of how to do something and then kind of applying that to a whole area yeah totally and so they're producing what looks like really interesting designs and patterns from relatively simple rules yeah this is awesome this reminds me
只是在讨论所有不同的生成方式。我，你知道，虽然文章没明确指出，但这非常类似于程序化生成。我觉得这很相似，你采用某种概念或描述，然后将其应用到整个区域。是的，完全正确。所以他们正在从相对简单的规则中产生看起来非常有趣的设计和图案。是的，这太棒了，这让我想起了
of uh and i think we talked about this years ago that cellular automata that made cave cave mazes oh yeah yeah yeah this is so cool i wonder you know i mean you could make a maze app for kids or you know they have to draw from one side to the other and it could just keep generating mazes it would never stop yeah cool but i mean i guess this is an interesting thing where you can make many valid mazes but if you don't kind of teach the computer what is an interesting maze then the maze could be really boring yeah right or super super hard right if there's only one path or something yeah and there's like ways of measuring that for mazes but people talk about the same thing for like sudoku that you know there's like the ratings on the puzzle and there's kind of a way to quantify how hard it
我们几年前谈论过的那个生成洞穴迷宫的元胞自动机。哦对，是的，这太酷了。我在想，你可以做一个给孩子玩的迷宫应用，他们必须从一端画到另一端，而且它可以不断生成迷宫，永远不会停止。是的，很酷。但我猜这是一个有趣的问题，你可以制作许多有效的迷宫，但如果你不教电脑什么是“有趣的迷宫”，那么迷宫可能会非常无聊，或者超级超级难，如果只有一条路径之类的。确实有衡量迷宫的方法，人们谈论数独时也是一样，谜题有难度等级，有一种量化难度的方法。
is but then there's an argument where people say oh humans create better sudoku puzzles because they kind of craft an experience through the solution versus the computer doesn't but over time the computer can be taught to do the same thing um and so it it doesn't work anymore there's a thing that still floats around i was reading some about it with the recent alpha go where people for a while the best chess the west best way to play chess was a you run a bunch of computers and then a human makes judgment call about which computers kind of giving the best answer and this kind of hybrid human and computer approach. And for a while that was like considered better than either humans or computers. And so a lot of people actually,
但也有人争论说，人类创造的数独谜题更好，因为他们通过解题过程精心设计了体验，而电脑则不然。但随着时间的推移，电脑可以被教导做同样的事情。所以这不再是问题了。最近AlphaGo出现时，还有一件事一直在流传。有一段时间，下棋最好的方式是运行一堆电脑，然后由人类判断哪台电脑给出的答案最好，这种人机结合的方法。有一段时间，这被认为比单纯的人类或电脑更好。所以很多人实际上，
that became kind of like a, a notion that a lot of people still think is true, even though now computers far surpass like if you a human gets involved, it'll just make it worse. And so actually what you're describing is kind of interesting because there's a surge in a new method. There's a ton of research papers that came out this year on this method called generative adversarial networks. And it's exactly what you described, except instead of a human, it's another algorithm. So basically, you have one algorithm or many that generate solutions, let's say, and then you have another algorithm that kind of gives you a thumbs up or a thumbs down.
这成为了一种很多人至今仍认为正确的观念，尽管现在电脑已经远远超过了人类，如果人类参与反而会使结果变差。所以你描述的其实很有趣，因为现在有一种新方法正在兴起。今年发表了大量关于这种叫“生成对抗网络”（GAN）的研究论文。这和你描述的完全一样，只是代替人类的是另一个算法。基本上，你有一个或多个算法来生成解决方案，然后你有另一个算法来给出“赞”或“踩”。
And the algorithms that got a thumbs down on their solution, they are disappointed. They kind of changed the way that their function works. And the ones that got a thumbs up, they're reinforced. They want to do that again. And so the idea is they actually used it for generating art. So they built this one algorithm. All it does is it looks at a bunch of fine works of art and a bunch of random images, and it learns to distinguish one from the other. And then they have a bunch of other algorithms that try to generate fine art. And this first one tells them how good they're doing.
那些解决方案被“踩”的算法会感到失望，它们会改变函数的工作方式；而那些被“赞”的算法会得到强化，它们想再次这样做。所以他们的想法是，实际上用它来生成艺术。他们构建了一个算法，它所做的只是观察一堆精美的艺术作品和一堆随机图像，并学会区分两者。然后他们有一堆其他算法试图生成艺术品，而第一个算法会告诉它们做得有多好。
And it turned out if you do this enough, you can actually make your own art generator where you kind of seed it with, like you could seed it with a picture of a robot and a Van Gogh painting, and it'll find some way to integrate those two together that makes the fine art algorithm happy oh interesting yeah yeah we'll make that a news next next month but yeah so anyways more
结果证明，如果你做得足够多，你实际上可以制作自己的艺术生成器。你可以用一张机器人的图片和一幅梵高的画作为种子，它会找到某种方式将两者结合起来，让那个艺术评估算法感到满意。哦，有趣。是的，我们下个月把它作为新闻吧。总之，更多
interesting mazes that was a little bit of a side stroll but yeah no that's totally awesome check it out has a bunch of really cool pictures of mazes very compelling makes you want to solve them all um uh i guess you can't though right because they don't have well you could if you because any two rooms are only connected in one way if you put a random start and a random finish anywhere there you go it'll be valid i think i didn't i didn't think all the way through that but yeah um all right my news is something pretty cool. It's called MyPy. It's static typing for Python 3. So you see a lot of languages that have this, like with dynamically typed languages,
有趣的迷宫，那是一个小小的题外话。但那真的很棒，去看看吧，里面有一堆非常酷的迷宫图片，非常引人入胜，让你想把它们全部解开。嗯，我想你解不开，对吧？因为它们没有……好吧，如果你愿意的话，因为任意两个房间只有一条路径相连，如果你在任何地方随机设置起点和终点，它就是有效的。我想我没完全想通这一点，但是的。好吧，我的新闻是一个很酷的东西，叫MyPy，它是Python 3的静态类型检查器。你看到很多语言都有这个，比如动态类型语言，
like they do this goofy thing with the annotations right at the top of the function. You do like at sign, int, and it just feels so like ugly and kind of hacky and crafted. This is not that. This is finally statically typed Python that looks nice. So, like, for example, in the, you know, function parameters,
它们在函数顶部做那种愚蠢的注解，比如用@符号加int，看起来非常丑陋、像黑客手段，而且是硬凑出来的。这不是那种。这终于成了看起来很漂亮的静态类型Python。所以，例如，在函数参数中，
it works just like, you know, hack did to PHP. So in the function parameters, you just put the name of the parameter, colon, the type. And if you don't put a type, it works just like Python. But if you put, you know, colon type, then mypy can do something, you know, do something clever with that. So, you know, if you, if your function is, you know, x colon int, and someone passes in john to your function, the mypy checker, it's not a compiler really, because the Python compiler handles that. This just checks it
它的工作方式就像Hack对PHP所做的那样。在函数参数中，你只需输入参数名，冒号，类型。如果你不输入类型，它的工作方式就和Python一样。但如果你输入了冒号类型，那么MyPy就可以做一些聪明的事情。所以，如果你的函数是x: int，而有人传了一个字符串“john”给你的函数，MyPy检查器（它不是真正的编译器，因为Python编译器处理那个）只是检查它，
and says, you know, no, you did something that's not legit. This is super, super important because of, you know, code aging and because of many people working on the same code base. I mean, if I have a function that takes two ints and a string and I decide that the middle int, I don't want it anymore, so I just delete it and people are calling into my function, Python will, well, depending on how the person calls into the function, Python might actually accept that. Like if I have an args component at the end or something.
并说：“不，你做了一些不合法的事情。”这非常非常重要，因为代码会老化，而且多人协作同一个代码库。我的意思是，如果我有一个函数接收两个整数和一个字符串，而我决定不再需要中间的那个整数，所以我把它删掉了，但人们还在调用我的函数，Python会……好吧，取决于调用者如何调用，Python实际上可能会接受它。比如如果我末尾有一个args组件之类的。
And it'll just, the program will behave in a very strange way and no one will know why. So this static checker catches those things. And I can't tell you how many times this has saved me in languages that have this like TypeScript and Hack and things like that. I mean, I've been, I constantly advocate for, you know, strong typed languages. And this kind of brings it to Python, which I think is pretty awesome. There seems to be the current trend is away from untyped or dynamically typed, I guess not untyped, but dynamically typed languages. The pendulum seems to have swung back to adding types or having types yeah i mean now that they have the uh what's it called um
程序会以非常奇怪的方式运行，没人知道为什么。所以这个静态检查器可以捕捉到这些问题。我无法告诉你这在TypeScript和Hack等语言中救了我多少次。我一直倡导强类型语言，而这把这种特性带到了Python，我觉得这非常棒。目前的趋势似乎是远离无类型或动态类型语言，我猜不是无类型，而是动态类型。钟摆似乎又摆回了添加类型或拥有类型的方向。是的，我的意思是，现在他们有了……叫什么来着？
like haskell and scala the type inferencing now that they have the type inferencing where most of the time you don't need a type but but some of the times you do. Like, for example, if you have a function, the parameters need to be typed because there's no information to be gleaned there, right? But if you have, you know, x equals 1, you don't need a type because it's just right there in front of you. And so, you know, type inferencing has allowed, you know, programming language designers to only, you know uh have you put a type when it's really needed and i think that has made strongly typed languages just you know much more like all the value is still there and the penalty is not so much well that's if you're very aggressive in using auto in c++ it's it's sort of the same way. A lot of times, auto is a shortcut for a very specific type
比如Haskell和Scala的类型推断，现在有了类型推断，大多数时候你不需要写类型，但有时需要。例如，如果有一个函数，参数需要类型化，因为那里没有信息可以获取，对吧？但如果你有x = 1，你不需要类型，因为它就在眼前。所以，类型推断允许编程语言设计者只让你在真正需要时才写类型，我认为这使得强类型语言的价值依然存在，而代价却没那么大。嗯，如果你在C++中非常积极地使用auto，情况也是一样的。很多时候，auto是特定类型的快捷方式，
and the type cannot change and it can only be one type. But the compiler will figure it out instead of you needing to write it out. Yeah, exactly. I don't know. Does your editor do this? If you go over,
类型不能改变，只能是一种类型。但编译器会弄清楚它，而不是让你写出来。是的，完全正确。我不知道，你的编辑器会这样做吗？如果你把鼠标悬停在变量上，
if you mouse over a variable, so I haven't done C++ in a long time. If you mouse over a variable that's auto, will it tell you the type? I use Eclipse and it won't. It will tell you if you got it wrong. Like if you have auto foo equals some constructor, and then you do foo dot, it knows the type of foo but if you hover over foo it just gives you the line where you defined it oh i see maybe it's just a ui change but for scala
我很久没用C++了。如果你把鼠标悬停在一个auto变量上，它会告诉你类型吗？我用Eclipse，它不会。如果你写了auto foo = 某个构造函数，然后你写foo.，它知道foo的类型，但如果你悬停在foo上，它只显示你定义它的那一行。哦，我明白了，也许这只是UI的变化。但对于Scala，
for scala whenever you hover over a variable eclipse tells you the type it's super valuable Yeah. Well, talking about C++, the 2016 CppCon just concluded and I had previously leading up to it. I guess I've never really traveled to a convention like CppCon or visited or attended. Seems like it would be cool. Yeah, just never gone. We should go. I mean, I feel like we're doing ourselves a disservice. There you go we'll have a boondoggle i mean business trip um yeah that's right what's the next one in hawaii yeah exactly i was thinking the same thing but there are several topics i caught my eye or i'd come across them in google searches um and the nice thing is after cpp con they do release all
每当你悬停在变量上时，Eclipse都会告诉你类型，这非常有价值。是的。说到C++，2016年的CppCon刚刚结束，我之前一直在关注。我猜我从来没有真正去过像CppCon这样的会议，或者参加过。看起来应该很酷。是的，只是从来没去过。我们应该去。我的意思是，我觉得我们亏待了自己。没错，我们可以去公费旅游，我是说商务旅行。是的，没错。下一个在夏威夷吗？是的，我刚才也在想。但有几个话题引起了我的注意，或者我在谷歌搜索时偶然发现了它们。好消息是，CppCon之后，他们会在YouTube上发布所有
the videos just on YouTube. And so it's not really a news article, but a helpful link is if you go to the uploads portion of the CppCon channel, which will link in the show notes, or you can just type CppCon, one word, into YouTube, you will see a list of the 2016 talks. I don't know if they're all up yet, but they have a whole bunch up now. It looks like they stopped uploading a couple of the 2016 talks i don't know if they're all up yet but they have a whole bunch up now it looks like they stopped uploading a couple days ago so they must be almost done or done yeah there's hours and hours and hours of talks there are and there are some really good ones in here like i don't want to name any because i know i'll mess some up but and also i'll butcher some of the speak many all the speakers names but herb sutter has some good ones in here about kind of how modern c++ should work and how you
视频。所以这不算新闻，但一个有用的链接是，如果你去CppCon频道的上传部分（我们会在节目说明中提供链接），或者你只需在YouTube上输入“CppCon”这个词，你就会看到2016年演讲的列表。我不知道它们是否都上传完了，但他们现在已经上传了很多。看起来他们几天前停止上传了，所以他们肯定快完成了，或者已经完成了。是的，那里有数小时的演讲。而且里面有一些非常好的演讲，我不想点名，因为我知道我会弄错，而且我还会把演讲者的名字读错。但Herb Sutter有一些关于现代C++应该如何工作，以及如何
should use pointers and memory ownership and transfer um that's really enlightening because a lot of people still develop c++ as they did a long time ago and c++ is well you can't i don't know if you can say it has changed i mean it has changed but you can still do all the old things but there are kind of newer ways that are mostly just strictly better yep um and so if you're not writing modern c++ most of the time you're probably missing out there are probably rare occasions where you shouldn't or can't, you don't have a compiler which supports modern C++. But there's a lot to offer and kind of the modern way of doing it.
使用指针和内存所有权与转移的演讲，这真的很有启发性。因为很多人仍然像很久以前那样开发C++，而C++……我不知道能不能说它变了，我的意思是它确实变了，但你仍然可以做所有旧的事情，但现在有一些更新的方法，它们在很大程度上是绝对更好的。是的。所以如果你不是在写现代C++，你可能错过了很多东西。可能在极少数情况下你不应该或不能使用，因为你没有支持现代C++的编译器。但现代开发方式确实有很多可取之处。
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. I mean, think about how many wasted, like how much wasted code is, you know, for int i equals zero or for some iterator you have to define it and increment it and you know and with auto i mean yeah there's a ton of new stuff it's really cool and so there's a lot of stuff in here i think even about proposals for i guess what will be 17 c++ 17 um and yeah i would all the talks i've watched or watched part of have seemed really well put together and I really liked what they were saying but I assume there's also stuff in here that's considered controversial
是的，绝对。我的意思是，想想有多少浪费的代码，比如for (int i = 0; ...)，或者对于某些迭代器，你必须定义它并递增它。有了auto，确实有很多新东西，真的很酷。这里面有很多内容，我想甚至还有关于C++17提案的内容。我观看或看过片段的所有演讲看起来都制作得非常好，我很喜欢他们所说的。但我假设这里面也有被认为有争议的内容，
or just someone's opinion about the best way to do stuff I've seen like a lot of convention drama recently there was a I can't remember I think it was Ruby on Rails there was a convention where a guy got kicked out. I guess he was making some rude jokes or something. But like, oh no, it wasn't Ruby on Rails.
或者只是某人关于做事方式的个人观点。我最近看到了很多会议上的闹剧，我记得好像是Ruby on Rails，有一个会议，一个人被踢出去了。我猜他讲了一些粗鲁的笑话之类的。但……哦不，不是Ruby on Rails。
It was Node.js. There's a Node.js conference and this guy made a couple of rude jokes. I didn't think they were that rude. They were kind of rude. And like they kicked him out. Like he was supposed to speak again the next day they kicked him out and then someone got kicked out of another conference a couple weeks later so yeah don't be rude at conferences i i was also wondering like what it takes to
是Node.js。有一个Node.js会议，这个家伙讲了几个粗鲁的笑话。我不觉得它们有多粗鲁，只是有点粗鲁。然后他们把他踢出去了。他本来第二天还要演讲的，他们把他踢出去了。然后几周后另一个人在另一个会议上也被踢出去了。所以，别在会议上表现得粗鲁。我也在想，要
present at such a conference like i mean i know you apply and you you kind of send in what you would like to talk about but i feel i would be feel very i mean we do this podcast but i would still feel very intimidated to get up at a you know cp c++ conference and present something c++ related uh personally i just find that like super scary yeah but they're i think they're all developers like you know they're all c++ so it's probably a pretty tight-knit community i would do my guess yeah if you went to them you probably wouldn't be i guess because i've never listened to a conference the thought of presenting at one seems really intimidating yeah i mean it it uh the thing about it is is the audience of c++
在这样的会议上演讲需要什么条件。我知道你需要申请，提交你想谈论的内容，但我会感到非常……我的意思是，我们做这个播客，但我仍然会觉得在C++会议上站起来演讲相关内容非常令人生畏。我个人觉得那太可怕了。是的，但我认为他们都是开发者，你知道，他们都是C++开发者，所以这可能是一个非常紧密的社区。我猜是这样。如果你去了，你可能就不会觉得了。因为我从来没听过会议，在会议上演讲的想法似乎非常令人生畏。是的，我的意思是，关于它的事情是，C++的受众
obviously enormous but like the developer base I don't know how many people do you think you know have written more than a thousand lines of the C++ compiler probably not that many maybe I see what you're saying so you're saying it isn't people who write C++ you're saying it's people who are kind of nerd out on the language itself yeah exactly so it's not c++ users but when you say c++ developers you mean people working on clang and gcc and yeah like libraries they might be you know hundreds of thousands of c++ developers who watch the talk but who actually go to the conference you know it's probably just a core group of people i guess i should have done more research for my news article i don't know what the intended audience for the conference yeah actually i'm just i mean i'm just
显然非常庞大，但开发者群体……我不知道你认为有多少人写过超过一千行C++编译器代码？可能没那么多。我明白你的意思了，所以你是说这不是写C++的人，而是那些对语言本身着迷的人。是的，完全正确。所以这不是C++用户，当你提到C++开发者时，你指的是那些在Clang和GCC上工作的人，以及库开发者。可能有成千上万的C++开发者观看演讲，但真正去参加会议的人，可能只是一个核心群体。我猜我应该为我的新闻文章做更多研究，我不知道会议的预期受众是谁。其实我只是……我只是
speculating i don't know either i assumed it was probably a c++ users conference um maybe yeah i wonder it's okay well there's so the videos have been up for six days and they have a thousand views. So yeah, I mean, it's probably, I mean, it's probably is for users, but hardcore ones like you. What? Oh, wait, that's a compliment. Nope. An insult.
在推测，我也不知道。我假设这是一个C++用户会议。也许吧。我很好奇，好吧，视频上传了六天，有一千次观看。所以，是的，它可能确实是给用户的，但像你这样的硬核用户。什么？哦，等等，那是恭维吗？不，是侮辱。
I'm not sure. No, it's definitely a compliment. All right. Well, time for book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show is a bit of a cop out um this is a website bayesian methods for hackers um we've covered this before yes it's a website as the website before yeah and this is a book so the website was so popular um they printed it out
我不确定。不，那绝对是恭维。好吧，现在是本期推荐书目时间。本期推荐书目。我的推荐书目有点偷懒，是一个网站：《贝叶斯方法黑客指南》。我们之前介绍过这个，是的，这是一个网站。之前介绍过这个网站。这本书是因为网站太受欢迎了，
i'm sure in in no small part because of us. And maybe because it was on the front page of hacker news for months and months. But, uh, uh, you know, the website was so unbelievably popular and so enamoring that, uh, they printed a book. Um, the book is literally the website, um, you know, in a, in a nice format. Um, but I think it's awesome. I'm going to pick it up. It's a great reference material. The thing about this Bayesian, it's really, a lot of it is about explaining uncertainty. And this is something that I honestly feel like
我相信很大程度上是因为我们。也许是因为它在Hacker News的头版挂了几个月。但那个网站太受欢迎、太迷人了，所以他们把它印成了书。这本书实际上就是那个网站的内容，以一种很好的格式呈现。但我认为它很棒，我打算买一本。它是一本很好的参考资料。关于贝叶斯，它很大程度上是在解释不确定性。这是我真心觉得
everyone with a CS degree needs to know. Like, let's say you do make, it's a good example. feel like everyone with a CS degree needs to know. Let's say you do make... That's a good example. Let's say you want to make an AI to play Risk. Well, Risk has a lot of chance, right? I mean, you roll the die, sometimes you win, but then there's... Forget about making an amazing player, but even just making a basic player, there's risk, but you have to kind of make decisions in a domain where you have this uncertainty and you have to be able to adapt to the uncertainty and kind of model that. And I definitely, when I got my degree, I had no idea how to do that. And I even, you know, I knew a lot of AI machine learning, but everything I knew was
每个计算机科学专业的学生都需要知道的东西。比如，假设你制作……这是一个很好的例子。每个计算机科学专业的学生都需要知道。假设你想制作一个玩《风险》（Risk）游戏的AI。嗯，《风险》有很多偶然性，对吧？你掷骰子，有时赢，有时输……别管制作一个顶尖玩家，即使只是制作一个基础玩家，也有风险，但你必须在有这种不确定性的领域做出决策，你必须能够适应不确定性并对其进行建模。我拿到学位时，完全不知道该怎么做。我甚至知道很多AI和机器学习知识，但我所知道的一切都是
what's called frequentist, which means you don't model the uncertainty. You know, if you flip a coin once and you get heads, you just say that coin can never be tails because I've never seen it. And so this is the heads coin. And you you could get you know far with that but i think whether you're doing machine learning or not you know every all of us who write software have to deal with uncertainty and uh for that reason i love this book because it caters for people with the cs degree and kind of walks you through how to deal with with you know these kind of walks you through how to deal with, with, you know, these kinds of circumstances. And if you ever played, you know, civilization or any of these games,
所谓的“频率派”（Frequentist），这意味着你不给不确定性建模。你知道，如果你掷一次硬币得到正面，你就说这枚硬币永远不可能是反面，因为我从没见过。所以这就是“正面硬币”。你可以用这种方法走得很远，但我认为无论你是否在做机器学习，我们所有写软件的人都必须处理不确定性。出于这个原因，我喜欢这本书，因为它迎合了有计算机科学学位的人，并引导你如何处理这些情况。如果你玩过《文明》或任何这类游戏，
and you think like, how does the AI do this? I mean, there's all this chance, like how does the AI, how can it plan for that? This book is, is for you.
你可能会想，AI是怎么做到的？有这么多偶然性，AI怎么能为此做计划？这本书就是为你准备的。
It's, it's a really good read. It's not hard, not too heavy and check it out. I read, which is not my book of the show, but I will mention it. Maybe I'll make it a future one. Is The Signal and the Noise?
这是一本非常好的书。它不难，不太沉重，去看看吧。我读过的一本书，虽然不是本期推荐，但我会提一下。也许以后我会推荐它。是《信号与噪声》（The Signal and the Noise）。
Oh, I've heard good things. Well, it's a, what would you call that, a popular book? No, it is popular, but it's written for a general audience. And so he does in there discuss exactly what you were talking about the difference between bayesian and frequentist views of the world and has some kind of cogent examples and talks about how predictions which is kind of like the the main subject of the book is about like bayesian thinking is about making predictions and evaluating if you got your prediction right or wrong yeah um and so how that in general we should be moving to that because it
哦，我听说过好评。嗯，它是一本……你会怎么称呼它，畅销书？不，它很受欢迎，但它是为大众读者写的。他在书中准确地讨论了你刚才谈到的贝叶斯观点和频率派观点之间的区别，并给出了一些令人信服的例子，谈到了预测——这算是书的主题——关于贝叶斯思维是如何进行预测并评估你的预测是对是错的。是的，所以我们总体上应该向那个方向发展，因为它
kind of better fits the world uh yeah i mean it's very hard uh just to like let people know why everything is in bayesian the problem is um instead of thinking about things in terms of numbers, you think about things in terms of distributions, kind of like the Schrodinger's cat. It's like this coin, you know, it isn't heads, it isn't tails, it's, you know, 50-50. And the problem is, the world is more entangled than we can understand. And not we as in human beings, but it's very hard to make a machine understand the entangled nature of the world. Like, for example,
更适合这个世界。是的，我的意思是，这非常难。要让人们知道为什么一切都是贝叶斯的，问题在于，你不是用数字来思考事物，而是用分布来思考，有点像薛定谔的猫。就像这枚硬币，它不是正面，也不是反面，它是50-50。问题是，世界比我们能理解的更纠缠。不是指人类，而是很难让机器理解世界的纠缠本质。例如，
if you have a feature in your model called day of week, it can't be Monday and Tuesday at the same time, right? Like, if it's Monday, you know it's not Tuesday. But, you know, for the model to learn that, it has to see all the pairs of features. I mean, if you tell it explicitly, then sure, right? But in general, the model has to look at all the interactions of all the variables to figure out which ones are sort of entangled. And that is super, super hard and it requires an unbelievable amount of data. So for these reasons, it's very hard to get Bayesian stuff to work when it gets really complicated.
如果你的模型中有一个特征叫“星期几”，它不可能同时是周一和周二，对吧？如果今天是周一，你就知道它不是周二。但是，为了让模型学到这一点，它必须看到所有特征对。我的意思是，如果你明确告诉它，那当然可以。但通常情况下，模型必须查看所有变量的相互作用，才能找出哪些是纠缠在一起的。这非常非常难，需要海量的数据。所以出于这些原因，当事情变得非常复杂时，很难让贝叶斯方法发挥作用。
And that's why when everything was complicated in the 60 the 60s and 70s people couldn't couldn't you know get there right but now it's starting to become more popular so i yeah that maybe i'll talk about in the future but he has a lot of case studies about kind of failures of prediction um anyways yeah yeah we should definitely uh do that because i've heard good things i haven't read it yet i'll read it there you've already read it and we'll talk about club our yeah uh so my actual book of the show which seems anticlimactic at this point is a zero to one by peter teal and i hope i'm saying that last name correct yeah and okay good and this is his view on startups on a broad ranging set of topics i guess and it is mostly about the difficulty exactly what the book describes of going from nothing to something which is as opposed to
这就是为什么在60年代和70年代，当一切都很复杂时，人们无法做到这一点。但现在它开始变得流行了，所以我可能会在未来谈论它。但他有很多关于预测失败的案例研究。总之，我们一定要做那一期，因为我听说过好评，但我还没读过。我会读的，你已经读过了，我们到时候再聊。所以，我真正的本期推荐书目，现在看来有点虎头蛇尾，是彼得·蒂尔（Peter Thiel）的《从0到1》。我希望我没读错他的姓。是的，很好。这是他对创业的看法，涵盖了广泛的话题。我猜，它主要描述了从无到有的困难，这与
what most companies do which is once you already have something trying to improve that something which is like from one to two, for instance. Right. And so going one to two is a very, very different problem than going zero to one and how that confusing the two is never going to really work for you. You're going to have problems.
大多数公司所做的事情相反，即一旦你已经有了某种东西，就试图改进它，比如从1到2。没错。所以从0到1是一个与从1到2完全不同的问题，混淆这两者永远不会奏效。你会遇到问题的。
That makes sense. It sounds really obvious when you say it that way. It's also him just kind of talking through some of the stuff behind what he's done, a little bit of a biography, I guess, with his work in PayPal. And then some notes about how, when he runs a venture capital firm, how interestingly, if you try to go for the companies
这很有道理。当你这样说的时候，听起来真的很明显。这也是他在谈论他所做的一些事情背后的经历，有点像传记，关于他在PayPal的工作。然后是一些关于他经营风险投资公司时的笔记，有趣的是，如果你试图去寻找那些公司……
you think have the highest probability of success and you build a portfolio out of them, your portfolio will probably not do very well what you actually want to do to some extent is increase the variance looking for companies that have a great idea but a very low chance of success but what you need is for them to go zero to one and return you know a hundred thousand times your investment and then it'll more than make up for all the other money you invested in the other companies and i see or and this is probably my opinion on kind of his his thinking there but the way i kind of take that away is when you hear people saying why in the world would people invest in this company that seems silly?
你认为成功概率最高，并以此构建投资组合，你的投资组合可能表现不会太好。你真正想要做的是在一定程度上增加方差，寻找那些有绝妙想法但成功概率极低的公司。你需要的是它们能从0到1，并为你带来十万倍的投资回报，这样就能弥补你在其他公司投入的所有资金。我明白，或者说这可能是我对他那种思维方式的看法，但我从中领悟到的是，当你听到人们说“为什么会有人投资这家公司，这看起来很傻？”时。
If it's silly because it's a radical idea, then it's probably very much merited, even if it's almost guaranteed to fail. But if you hear about a venture capital firm investing in something that has a very low chance of returning 100,000x on, even if it's successful, it's not going to move the market, then that actually might be a venture capital firm that isn't of the same caliber of what Peter Thiel is advocating
如果它看起来傻是因为这是一个激进的想法，那么它很可能是值得的，即使它几乎注定会失败。但如果你听说一家风险投资公司投资了一个即使成功也无法撼动市场、回报率远达不到10万倍的项目，那么这家风投公司可能并不具备彼得·蒂尔所倡导的那种水准。
is kind of the right way to do that investment. Oh, that makes sense. This sounds like there's something called novelty search and it works like this. You, so the idea is you have kind of some function you can give it inputs you can get an output and the way novelty search works is novelty search if you give it a certain set of inputs you win but you don't really know what those are so with a regular type of search you know you would start with something random and then you'd start with something a little different and you'd see kind of did it get better or worse this is called hill climbing and as you just keep tweaking things tweaking things you get better better better
这才是那种投资的正确方式。哦，这很有道理。听起来有一种东西叫“新颖性搜索”（novelty search），它是这样运作的：这个想法是，你有一个函数，可以输入数据并得到输出。新颖性搜索的运作方式是，如果你输入一组特定的输入，你就赢了，但你并不知道那些输入是什么。所以，在常规搜索中，你会从随机的东西开始，然后尝试一点点不同的东西，看看它是否变得更好或更差，这被称为“爬山法”。随着你不断调整，你会变得越来越好。
better better and at some point you get to the point where no matter what you change it gets worse that's called a local optimum and you just say okay i'm done um novelty search is kind of interesting you feed in a set of inputs and then you feed in, you know, a different set of inputs. And if you get the same answer, that's bad. So if I feed in, you know, the second thing and I got the same answer, like, you know, I want to stay away from that part of the input space. So if I feed in, you know, if I change the second variable just a little bit and I get a totally different answer, then I know, aha, the second variable, that's where all the interesting, that's where all the variance is.
越来越好，在某个点上，无论你怎么改变，它都会变差，这被称为“局部最优”，你就会说“好吧，我完成了”。嗯，新颖性搜索很有趣，你输入一组输入，然后输入另一组不同的输入。如果你得到相同的答案，那就不好了。所以如果我输入第二组东西，得到了相同的答案，我就想远离那部分的输入空间。所以如果我改变第二个变量一点点，得到了完全不同的答案，那么我就知道，啊哈，第二个变量，那才是所有有趣的地方，那才是所有方差所在的地方。
And so it's kind of like you don't even care about the answer you get. You just care that it's different from the other answers you've seen before um and so that's it's interesting like peter deal is basically advocating novelty search when you're investing which sounds super dangerous but i mean it makes sense i guess i mean if they find that if that one thing they find is that valuable then it makes sense he also has thoughts about monopolies which is interesting and how monopolies can be good and you really want to invest in them uh but you know kind of like what are the downfalls of it but you know he talks about a lot of people kind of think they have monopoly but they don't and then you just end up in a market that's a race to the bottom um i see and then how like he has some thoughts about
所以你甚至不在乎你得到的答案是什么，你只在乎它是否和你之前看到的其他答案不同。这很有趣，彼得·蒂尔基本上是在倡导投资时使用新颖性搜索，这听起来超级危险，但我觉得这说得通。如果他们发现的那一件东西真的那么有价值，那就说得通了。他还对垄断有自己的看法，这很有趣，比如垄断如何可能是好的，你确实想投资它们。但他谈到很多人以为自己拥有垄断地位，但其实并没有，最后你只会陷入一场逐底竞争的市场。我明白了，还有他关于……
is google a monopoly and like why or why not? Or like a de facto monopoly? You know, anyways, it's interesting. I don't want to, you know, spoil it all or give my interpretation, which is probably not right. So go listen to him tell it. And I will totally, totally check that out. Although I guess now he's gotten into like some political stuff. So people might not like this suggestion of mine.
谷歌是否是垄断企业，以及为什么是或不是？或者说它是否是事实上的垄断？总之，这很有趣。我不想剧透，也不想给出我自己的解读，因为那可能是不对的。所以去听他自己讲吧。我绝对会去看看。虽然我想现在他卷入了一些政治事务，所以人们可能不会喜欢我的这个建议。
Oh, yeah. This is not in regards to that. This is just in regards to the book and him talking about startups that's why we were like racing each other to give that disclaimer i mean i don't want to get involved this is uh this has nothing to do with politics at all this is peter thiel talking about his companies he has a lot of interesting political views as well and that some of those are in this book but not his really recent ones because this book's a little bit old i don't remember when it was released and uh so you know we this is a portion of show where we get to plug some stuff and i actually did listen to this book and all the books i listened to because i have a long commute on audible and we do have a affiliate link with audible and if you go to that link you can get a
哦，是的。这与那些无关。这只是关于那本书以及他谈论创业公司的内容。这就是为什么我们刚才抢着做免责声明。我的意思是，我不想卷入其中，这与政治完全无关。这是彼得·蒂尔在谈论他的公司。他也有很多有趣的政治观点，其中一些在书里，但不是他最近的观点，因为这本书有点老了。我不记得它是什么时候出版的。所以，这是我们节目中插播广告的部分，我确实听了这本书，因为我通勤时间很长，我都在Audible上听书。我们确实有Audible的联盟链接，如果你通过那个链接，你可以获得一个……
free credit which is good for basically any book that they have in their library of which they have many many many books and if you go through our link then we get a little bit you can help the show and get a free book and then you can cancel after you get the book or if you don't then you'll just get a monthly subscription and get a book every month, which is what I have. And actually, my wife started listening. I don't know if we can say that on air. Oh, well, my wife shares my account. And so it lets us do that.
免费积分，基本上可以兑换他们库里的任何一本书，他们有很多很多书。如果你通过我们的链接，我们能得到一点支持，你可以帮助节目并获得一本免费书。之后你可以取消订阅，或者如果你不取消，你就会获得每月订阅，每个月得到一本书，我就是这样。其实我妻子也开始听了。我不知道能不能在节目里说这个。哦，好吧，我妻子共享我的账户，所以这让我们能这样做。
That's fine. People won't judge. I hear everybody talk about HBO all the time. Apparently, there's like only one HBO login in the whole world. With Hulu, I think it's, no, sorry, not Hulu. With Spotify, they crack down. I know, yeah, like Hulu and Netflix, like there's a limit to how many streams.
没关系，人们不会评判的。我一直听到大家谈论HBO。显然，全世界好像只有一个HBO登录账号。对于Hulu，我想是……不，抱歉，不是Hulu。对于Spotify，他们打击得很严。我知道，是的，像Hulu和Netflix，流媒体数量是有限制的。
Anyways, this is off topic. So, you know, now my wife's actually gotten some books and so she's been, she's like, wow, this really actually is good. I enjoy listening to these books while I'm in the car where I would otherwise just listen to the same songs again or whatever. Yeah, I need to do this. You know, I've been reading books on the bus.
总之，这跑题了。所以，现在我妻子也开始听书了，她说：“哇，这真的很好。”我喜欢在车里听这些书，否则我只会一遍又一遍地听同样的歌之类的。是的，我需要这样做。你知道，我一直在公交车上看书。
And lately I've been like, lately I've had to work a lot of overtime. And I've been reading books. I feel like, you know, doing slow but permanent damage to my eyes. Like maybe, you know, listening to books, even though I'm on a bus, you know, just closing my eyes or looking out the window and listening to books would probably be much healthier. I knew someone who listened to books while they were working.
最近我一直在加很多班，我一直在看书。我觉得这对我眼睛造成了缓慢但永久的伤害。也许听书，即使我在公交车上，闭上眼睛或看着窗外听书，可能会更健康。我认识一个人，他在工作时听书。
I can't do that. Like it's too distracting. Yeah. But while I'm in the car or whenever, like, yeah, I do it. I mean, you can also listen to podcasts like this fine podcast. That's right. Don't get an an audible subscription if you have to choose between audible and our podcast but if you have the luxury of doing both which you should because we're only on once a month then uh check out audible you go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown all one word um we also have patreon so patreon is a is a pretty cool service
我做不到，太让人分心了。是的。但在车里或任何时候，我确实会听。我的意思是，你也可以听像我们这个很棒的播客。没错。如果你必须在Audible和我们的播客之间做选择，别去订阅Audible，但如果你有余力两者兼顾（你应该这样做，因为我们一个月才更新一次），那就去看看Audible。你可以访问audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，全部连在一起。我们还有Patreon，Patreon是一个很酷的服务。
you can actually download the episodes from patreon i know some of our russian friends can't can't get the episodes from their source i'm still looking into like a better way to to handle that but at the moment you can download mp3s from our website or from patreon which has a really high high speed connection um if you're a patreon subscriber um you go to patreon.com slash programming throwdown um it's as little as i think a dollar is the minimum a dollar a month i don't know if you can donate it's an episode right it's per episode yeah i mean we keep the episodes once a month we're not going to like accidentally we're not going to purposely shill you and put 10 episodes a month or something i don't think we can even do that
你可以直接从Patreon下载剧集。我知道我们的一些俄罗斯朋友无法从他们的源获取剧集，我还在寻找更好的处理方法，但目前你可以从我们的网站或Patreon下载MP3，那里的连接速度非常快。如果你是Patreon订阅者，访问patreon.com/programmingthrowdown，最低只需一美元，一美元一个月。我不知道你能不能捐赠，这是按剧集算的，对吧？是的，我的意思是，我们保持一个月一集的频率，我们不会故意骗你，然后一个月发10集什么的，我觉得我们甚至做不到那样。
episode part one episode part two yeah right um but yeah anything you give helps out the show it goes to things like uh you know designing this t-shirt. So we appreciate all of your donations. So being the last episode before the election, I have to make one joke based on what you said about, which you are right, several people have written in that they can't download from Russia, but they can read all of our politicians' emails. They can't listen to this podcast.
剧集第一部分，剧集第二部分，是的，没错。但你给的任何支持都有助于节目，它会用于设计这件T恤之类的事情。所以我们感谢你们所有的捐赠。作为选举前的最后一集，我必须根据你刚才说的话开个玩笑，你是对的，有几个人写信说他们无法从俄罗斯下载，但他们可以阅读我们所有政客的邮件。他们却听不了这个播客。
That's our problem. We didn't have our rss feed on wikileaks so we just need julian assange to decide that this is controversial and then everyone can get a chance to listen to it yes julian if you're hearing this uh i'm sure he listens yes i'm sure he listens hack my computer and take all my programming through episodes, but please leave my credit cards intact. Please no one do that to any of my stuff. Yeah, I mean, yeah, joking aside, don't ruin my life, please. I know some people out there are good enough to do that,
这是我们的问题。我们没有把RSS订阅源放在维基解密上，所以我们只需要朱利安·阿桑奇决定这很有争议，然后每个人都有机会听了。是的，朱利安，如果你在听的话……我相信他会听的。是的，我相信他会听。黑进我的电脑，拿走我所有的Programming Throwdown剧集，但请别动我的信用卡。请别对我的任何东西做那种事。是的，不开玩笑了，别毁了我的生活，拜托。我知道有些人有能力做到这一点。
Uber hackers, and that would make my life hard. Tool of the show. Tool of the show. My tool of the show is, how show my tool of the show is how do you say the term meter why is every meter oh sorry i won't interrupt you oh just termiter which is supposed to be like thermometer or something i don't know but the idea so i uh um the way i work is I write a lot of kind of scripty tool kind of things, prototypes, things like that. And I want to work very quickly. And usually the code I write has to be rewritten.
超级黑客，那会让我的生活变得很艰难。本期工具。本期工具。我的工具是……怎么说那个词？Termitor？为什么是Termitor？哦，抱歉，我不打断你。哦，只是Termitor，听起来像温度计（thermometer）之类的，我不知道。但这个想法是……我工作的习惯是写很多脚本工具、原型之类的东西。我想工作得非常快。通常我写的代码都需要重写。
Like once, you know, the target keeps moving, we're learning a lot. And then we say, OK, this model works now. Rewrite it. So for this reason, like I need to work fast. And usually, you know, I'm writing all this code. I have a bunch of prints. It's in Python. I'm like printing a bunch of things.
比如，目标一直在变，我们学到了很多。然后我们说：“好的，这个模型现在能用了，重写它。”所以出于这个原因，我需要快速工作。通常我写这些代码时，会有很多print语句，是在Python里。我打印了很多东西。
And then I kind of have to look through and I see, okay, here's a print saying, you know, iteration two and then some data and then iteration three and then some data. And I have to like in my head kind of get the average of all these iterations. And it's just kind of a mess and it's and sometimes i'm just wrong like i just misread it or i think the average is this just from eyeballing it and when i go further down it's really something else and basically what i need is a way to go from prints in python to a graph but i need it to be just very, very easy. If it takes more than 10 minutes, it's not worth it. I could just eyeball it.
然后我得翻看，看到：“好的，这里有个print显示迭代2，然后是一些数据，然后是迭代3，然后是一些数据。”我得在脑子里算出所有这些迭代的平均值，这简直是一团糟。有时我就是错了，我读错了，或者我凭直觉认为平均值是这个，但当我往下看时，它其实是另一个值。基本上我需要一种方法，能把Python里的print变成图表，而且必须非常非常简单。如果超过10分钟，就不值得了，我可以直接凭直觉看。
And Termitor does this. It's amazing. Basically, it uses Unix pipes to stream in data. If you don't know what this is, check out our Unix commands episode. But you could stream in numbers to this termiter and it will turn it into a plot right there in your terminal so so you could say like print and then do like asdf asdf asdf and then some data then you know you're going to get all this prints
而Termitor做到了这一点。太棒了。基本上，它使用Unix管道来流式传输数据。如果你不知道这是什么，去看看我们的Unix命令那一集。但你可以把数字流式传输给这个Termitor，它会直接在你的终端里把它变成图表。所以你可以说print，然后做一些asdf asdf asdf，然后是一些数据，你知道你会得到所有这些print。
with all these different things you could do a grep for that asdf so on so now you only have those lines that have those numbers that you want and you can you know cut out those numbers pipe them to termiter and you have a graph so um it's super super powerful i've been using it a lot it's a lot of fun i actually wrote my own before someone told me about this um the one i wrote actually does png so i think i'll keep mine but uh uh but this is this is totally awesome and it's uh um it's right there on github now i'm distracted because the movie of the example is this website asciCII Cinema. And so they have a whole bunch of ASCII art movies. Now I'm distracted by clicking on random ASCII art movies. So if nothing else, go to this GitHub page. I really encourage you to get it.
你可以用grep过滤那些asdf，这样你现在就只有那些你想要的数字行了，你可以切出那些数字，通过管道传给Termitor，你就得到了一张图表。所以它超级超级强大，我一直在用它，很有趣。其实在别人告诉我这个之前，我自己写过一个，我写的那个其实生成的是PNG，所以我想我会保留我自己的，但这绝对太棒了，它就在GitHub上。现在我分心了，因为这个例子的电影是这个网站ASCII Cinema。他们有一大堆ASCII艺术电影。现在我被点击随机ASCII艺术电影分心了。所以如果没别的，去看看这个GitHub页面，我强烈建议你下载它。
But if you don't, check out the ASCII art movie. And then, yeah, follow all of the other ones on that website. Nice. So my tool is, unfortunately, this is only, as far as I know, on the iPhone. But they have an equivalent on Android as well. And that is Motion Stills. And so this is a product that was released by Google. And then I don't think it got a lot of traction. But they did integrate the technology that was a part of it into Google Photos.
但如果你不下载，去看看那个ASCII艺术电影。然后，是的，关注那个网站上的所有其他内容。不错。所以我的工具是，不幸的是，据我所知，它只在iPhone上有。但Android上也有类似的。那就是Motion Stills。这是谷歌发布的一款产品。我不认为它获得了很大的关注，但他们确实把其中的技术集成到了Google Photos中。
So I think this is how you can get to it in Google Photos. But I will say if you have an iPhone, it's worth checking out, even though it's if you also already have Google Photos, which is awesome. And you should get Google Photos. I do recommend Google Photos. Yeah, me too. And so what this will do is on your iphone if you take a live photo or you take a movie it will do uh i guess essentially image stabilization on the kind of movie that you have so that the things that are actually moving in the scene kind of pop out to a greater extent and oh is that what it's doing i was wondering what it was
所以我认为这就是你在Google Photos中找到它的方式。但我得说，如果你有iPhone，它值得一试，即使你已经有了Google Photos，它也很棒。你应该下载Google Photos。我也推荐Google Photos。是的，我也是。它在你的iPhone上所做的是，如果你拍摄了一张实况照片（Live Photo）或电影，它会进行图像稳定处理，这样场景中真正移动的东西会更加突出。哦，这就是它在做的事情吗？我一直在想它在做什么。
doing right and so the reason you think oh that's not that big of a deal except that when you have the looping happen and you manage to before i had kind of live photos turned off and i thought it was just a waste of space uh but now i've turned it on almost exclusively because of this most of the time it kind of is just like, oh, that's silly or it doesn't work. But occasionally you just manage to capture something where if you're handholding the phone, it moves just enough that you've ruined the effect.
没错，你可能会觉得这没什么大不了的，但当你循环播放时，在你成功之前……我以前把实况照片关掉了，觉得那只是浪费空间。但现在我几乎专门把它打开了，就是因为这个。大多数时候它看起来就像“哦，那很傻”或者它不起作用。但偶尔你确实能捕捉到一些东西，如果你手持手机，它移动得刚好足够多，以至于毁了效果。
But if you run it through the motion stills and you get the live photo where it's just like a person moving or turning to face the camera as you tell them, you know, smile. And then you take the picture that you get this really cool you know much more artistic effect yeah it's like the whole world is frozen except for your friend well it looks yeah more like a cinema or a movie where you have a
但如果你通过Motion Stills运行它，你得到的实况照片就像是一个人移动或转过身面对镜头，当你告诉他们“笑一个”时。然后你拍下照片，你就会得到这种非常酷的、更具艺术感的效果。是的，就像整个世界都冻结了，只有你的朋友在动。看起来更像电影，或者你有……
stabilized camera uh but when you're hand-holding you almost always get some vibration in the movie yeah this is so so cool yeah i uh i didn't know but so wait so if you have google photos you already have this is that right i believe that for movies i don't know i assume for live photos isn't a thing in android but if you have a movie i would assume that google photos either at least has an op is what i read has an option to do this or we'll do it automatically for your movies cool where it'll try youtube has that as well where it'll try to motion stabilize the movies very cool i'll try this out that was you should just go watch the videos on search motion stills and watch the videos because i'm
稳定的摄像机。但当你手持时，电影里几乎总会有一些抖动。是的，这太酷了。是的，我不知道……等等，所以如果你有Google Photos，你已经有了这个，对吧？我相信对于电影来说……我不知道，我假设实况照片在Android上不是一回事，但如果你有电影，我假设Google Photos至少有一个选项可以这样做，或者会自动为你的电影处理。很酷，YouTube也有这个功能，它会尝试对电影进行运动稳定。非常酷，我会试试这个。你应该去搜索Motion Stills并观看视频，因为我……
sure my description of it was butchering it no no i thought it was solid it makes sense cool um okay so now we're the topic of the show the topic which is distribution you deploying software you wouldn't think that this would be hard it is it's one of these things that kind of creeps up on you um as a developer you don't really expect this to be a problem um like where do we? I guess we start with applications that's kind of the most straightforward the most obvious question is, I built this thing, it works on my computer why don't I just zip it up and email it to someone? I mean that seems very logical
肯定把我的描述搞砸了。不，不，我觉得很扎实，很有道理。酷。好的，现在我们进入节目的主题，主题是分发，你部署软件。你不会觉得这很难，但它确实很难。这是那种会悄悄找上你的事情之一。作为开发者，你真的没预料到这会是个问题。比如我们在哪里？我想我们从应用程序开始，这是最直接的。最明显的问题是：我构建了这个东西，它在我的电脑上运行，为什么我不直接把它压缩起来发邮件给别人？这看起来很合乎逻辑。
if you try this, here's what will happen you and possibly your friends, it will run no problem. But for most people, it won't work. And the reason why is everyone's operating system is in a different state. I mean, you might have developer tools that most people don't have installed. You might even have just, you know, a slightly different version of Windows. Like it's still Windows 10 or XP or whatever you're running. But it's just, you have a couple of security patches or a couple of updates that other people don't have. And when it goes to their computer it just blows up, it ends badly
如果你尝试这样做，会发生什么：你和你的朋友可能运行没问题。但对大多数人来说，它不会工作。原因在于每个人的操作系统处于不同的状态。我的意思是，你可能安装了大多数人没有的开发工具。你甚至可能只是有稍微不同版本的Windows。比如它仍然是Windows 10或XP或任何你运行的版本，但你有一些其他人没有的安全补丁或更新。当它传到他们的电脑上时，它就崩溃了，结果很糟糕。
so basically don't zip up your program and send it to someone you can do that if it's your friend and if it doesn't work it's ok but don't zip your program up and email it to your whole school it's just not going to work I guess surprisingly it actually is shocking that it
所以基本上，不要把你的程序压缩起来发给别人。如果是发给朋友，如果不能运行也没关系，但不要把你的程序压缩起来发给全校的人，它就是不会工作的。我想令人惊讶的是，它实际上……
does work sometimes like if you think about all the chances for it to go wrong different processors different whatever but it actually has a non-zero chance of working and that actually is kind of amazing in itself is that you can't true. You can't email, you know, you can't email random, like stuff from Windows to Linux, like that won't ever work because of kind of how the syscalls work between the different operating systems. But if you email it to, you know, your friends and family, there is actually a chance of where, and that's actually kind of cool because of how, and that's one of the purposes of the operating system itself is to make it so that you don't have to be specific to the exact processor you're on
有时确实能工作。如果你考虑到所有可能出错的机会：不同的处理器，不同的什么什么，但它确实有非零的成功概率，这本身就很神奇。你不能……没错。你不能通过邮件发送，你知道，你不能把Windows的东西发给Linux，那永远不会工作，因为不同操作系统之间的系统调用（syscalls）工作方式不同。但如果你发给朋友和家人，确实有机会成功，这其实很酷，因为操作系统的目的之一就是让你不必针对你所处的具体处理器。
or to the exact configuration of everything but then like jason said there's also a lot of things that can go wrong uh and so one of those things that can go wrong are your dependencies which is the stuff that your programmer lies on that you may not realize at first which is uh you know if i install and it depends on what language you're in how obvious your dependencies are but in python for instance if you've just you know pip installed something on your computer and you send your python script to someone else and they try to run it and they're like it won't work right that's not sending a binary i guess but sending that script and it doesn't work is because you installed something and they didn't. Yep. That's right. But even for something like
或者不必针对所有东西的具体配置。但就像杰森说的，也有很多事情会出错。其中之一就是你的依赖项，也就是你的程序所依赖的东西，你起初可能没意识到。比如，如果你安装了……这取决于你使用的语言，你的依赖项有多明显。但在Python中，如果你只是在你的电脑上pip安装了什么，然后把Python脚本发给别人，他们尝试运行它，他们会说“它不能运行”。对，那不是发送二进制文件，我想，但发送那个脚本却不能运行，是因为你安装了什么，而他们没有。是的，没错。但即使对于像……
C++, if I use, uh, for instance, direct X and I, well, I guess this isn't true. It is included now, I think, but if I sent it to Jason and Jason didn't have the same version of DirectX installed as me. Yeah, if you used OpenAL or something. Right. Then I'm depending on some code that isn't shipped with the source code that I compiled. And that would happen if I'm using specifically a shared library, which is some binary that's compiled that isn't an executable but is on my computer. And on Windows, those would be dlls or sos on linux and even like you know no matter how even the most professional software development studios still have this issue to deal with like that's why when you install a game on steam
C++，如果我使用，比如DirectX，我……好吧，我想这不是真的。我想现在它已经包含在内了，但如果我把它发给杰森，而杰森没有安装和我相同版本的DirectX。是的，如果你使用了OpenAL之类的。没错。那么我就依赖于一些没有随我编译的源代码一起发布的代码。如果我专门使用共享库，就会发生这种情况，这是一种编译好的二进制文件，它不是可执行文件，但在我的电脑上。在Windows上，这些是DLL，在Linux上是SO。即使是即使是最专业的软件开发工作室也仍然要处理这个问题。这就是为什么当你安装Steam上的游戏时……
you get that little box saying you know checking for direct x installing direct x it's because nobody can guarantee that you have it so everyone just makes you know, checking for DirectX, installing DirectX. It's because nobody can guarantee that you have it. So everyone just makes you at least check for it. Right. And so part of distribution is making sure that the shared libraries that are expected on your system are there and that they have a compatible version because maybe the person has an older one or a newer one that is incompatible with your version. And so sometimes you end up with it must be greater than and sometimes must be between and sometimes must be equal to the version of that library. That's right.
你会看到那个小框说“检查DirectX，安装DirectX”。这是因为没人能保证你有它，所以每个人都让你……检查DirectX，安装DirectX。这是因为没人能保证你有它。所以每个人都至少让你检查一下。没错。所以分发的一部分是确保系统上预期的共享库都在那里，并且它们有兼容的版本，因为也许那个人有一个旧版本，或者一个与你的版本不兼容的新版本。所以有时你会遇到“必须大于”、“必须介于”和“必须等于”该库的版本。没错。
And even if sometimes you don't have shared dependencies or shared libraries, but sometimes there are static libraries where the library is compiled into your binary itself. And that's one way to avoid having to check for it on someone's system is to just include it in yours when you send it. The problem there is that that's duplicate code. So it makes your binary bigger because you have to ship with all of the code you use instead of everyone being able to share the same code that is the same.
即使有时你没有共享依赖项或共享库，但有时会有静态库，库被编译进你的二进制文件本身。这是避免在别人系统上检查它的一种方法，就是当你发送它时，把它包含在你的程序里。问题在于那是重复的代码。所以它会让你的二进制文件变大，因为你必须随身携带你使用的所有代码，而不是每个人都能共享相同的代码。
That's right. And also, some people won't give you a static library. Like DirectX, I don't believe they have static libraries. That's a good point. Also, it's a little bit of a trap. Sometimes a static library will refer to a shared library, and you won't even know that now you're depending on some shared library that you didn't know about. So yeah, there's a
没错。而且，有些人不会给你静态库。比如DirectX，我不认为他们有静态库。这是一个很好的观点。而且，这有点像个陷阱。有时静态库会引用一个共享库，你甚至不知道现在你依赖于一些你不知道的共享库。所以，是的，有很多……
bunch of gotchas. There's certain like low-level tricks you can do. Like there's this thing called dependency walker, but you don't want to do any of this. You want an installer that will do this for you. This is kind of like writing your own compiler. You don't want to do this. I mean, unless that's your expertise. So there's a bunch of installers. For Windows, there's something called NSYS, which is a null-soft scriptable install system.
很多陷阱。有一些底层技巧你可以做。比如有个东西叫Dependency Walker，但你不想做这些。你想要一个能为你做这些的安装程序。这有点像写你自己的编译器。你不想做这个。我的意思是，除非那是你的专长。所以有很多安装程序。对于Windows，有个东西叫NSIS，即Nullsoft可脚本化安装系统。
On OS X, there's Sparkle, which is very popular. And on Linux, there's PPA, Personal Package Archives. They all sort of have kind of different procedures for building your package and deploying it and things like that. One thing I strongly recommend, if you're planning on deploying software to customers or to strangers or to any large group of people, get VirtualBox and get a version of Windows, a vanilla version of Windows, maybe even two different versions of Windows and a version
在OS X上，有Sparkle，非常流行。在Linux上，有PPA，个人软件包存档。它们都有不同的程序来构建你的包、部署它等等。我强烈建议，如果你打算向客户、陌生人或任何大型群体部署软件，买一个VirtualBox，弄一个Windows版本，一个纯净版的Windows，甚至可能是两个不同版本的Windows，以及一个……
of Linux or what have you, and make sure that you can install your program on that machine, that virtual machine that doesn't have anything else installed chances are the first time you try nine times out of ten you know you'll run your program and it'll pop up an error saying oops you know you don't have you know visual studio developer files or something like that and you'll have to add that to your installer so it's also worth pointing out for large projects and large programs that doing the installer and distribution and checking compatibility on the platforms is a job for people or people's unto itself but for a small team or program you know a person is probably doing this along with doing other stuff yeah and it's very time consuming um you know when i release maim hub um i mean especially now that maim hub's been around for
Linux版本或其他什么，确保你可以在那台机器上安装你的程序，那台没有安装任何其他东西的虚拟机。很有可能第一次尝试时，十次有九次你会运行你的程序，它会弹出一个错误说“哎呀，你没有Visual Studio开发文件”之类的，你必须把它添加到你的安装程序中。所以也值得指出的是，对于大型项目和大型程序，做安装程序、分发和检查平台兼容性本身就是一项工作。但对于小团队或程序，一个人可能在做这个的同时还在做其他事情。是的，而且非常耗时。你知道，当我发布MAME Hub时……我的意思是，特别是现在MAME Hub已经存在……
so many years i mean i spend more time on the installer than anything else to this day i mean the past maybe three years every year i've spent more time having maintenance issues on the installer than anything else. Another way, I mean, people have obviously gotten sick of building installers and definitely zipping their binary. So they have app stores. You could consider Steam as an app store, right? Windows has an app store. Apple, obviously, with iOS and OS X, they have the app stores. They're called app store. Apple, obviously, you know, with iOS and OS X, they have the app stores. They're called App Store.
这么多年了，我的意思是，直到今天，我花在安装程序上的时间比其他任何事情都多。我的意思是，过去三年，每年我花在安装程序维护问题上的时间都比其他任何事情都多。另一种方法是，人们显然已经厌倦了构建安装程序，绝对厌倦了压缩二进制文件。所以他们有了应用商店。你可以把Steam看作一个应用商店，对吧？Windows有应用商店。苹果，显然，iOS和OS X，他们有应用商店。它们被称为应用商店。苹果，显然，你知道，iOS和OS X，他们有应用商店。它们被称为App Store。
Android has the Play Store. And basically, along with the store, there's also, like, developer support. So if you want to make a Windows app for the Windows App Store, they've made it as simple as possible where you hit some button and it does everything it needs to do so that when someone gets that app from the store that it will work on their computer. They provide pretty good guarantees for that. Yeah. So there's a way to package and describe the needs of your app in a consistent way so that it works for everyone. Exactly.
Android有Play Store。基本上，随着商店的出现，还有开发者支持。所以如果你想为Windows应用商店制作一个Windows应用，他们把它做得尽可能简单，你点击某个按钮，它就会做所有需要做的事情，这样当有人从商店获取那个应用时，它就能在他们的电脑上运行。他们为此提供了相当好的保证。是的。所以有一种一致的方式来打包和描述你的应用需求，这样它对每个人都有效。没错。
I guess Steam's a little bit different there because i don't think steam has the same level of integration with that um does it i actually have no idea how steam works i mean i'm assuming that there is steam i'm assuming that steam integrates with visual studios somehow uh but uh But I don't know. It's a good question. But the continuous, sorry, the way that Steam is kind of different is that Steam has a wide variety. It has DOS programs. It really has to support a much broader base than something like iOS,
我想Steam在那方面有点不同，因为我不认为Steam有那种程度的集成。它有吗？我其实不知道Steam是怎么运作的。我的意思是，我假设有Steam，我假设Steam以某种方式与Visual Studio集成。但……但我不知道。这是一个好问题。但持续的……抱歉，Steam的不同之处在于Steam有广泛的种类。它有DOS程序。它确实必须支持比iOS更广泛的基础，
where you know everyone's running Xcode. Or not everyone, but most people are using some variant of Xcode or Xcode build. So yeah, Steam, actually, it's really interesting. If you work for Valve and you're listening right now, write in. And we're super interested how Steam actually works from the developer side. So related to this topic, but not quite what we've been talking about, so change of topics lately, is continuous delivery. And we'll talk about continuous deployment. And this is talking about you write the source code as a developer and then assume you have a system that produces the installer that describes the dependencies, that packages it up and ships it.
你知道每个人都在运行Xcode。或者不是每个人，但大多数人都在使用某种变体的Xcode或Xcode构建。所以是的，Steam，其实这真的很有趣。如果你为Valve工作，现在正在听，写信告诉我们。我们超级想知道Steam从开发者角度到底是怎么运作的。所以与这个话题相关，但不完全是我们一直在谈论的，所以换个话题，是持续交付。我们将谈论持续部署。这是在谈论你作为开发者编写源代码，然后假设你有一个系统，它能生成描述依赖项的安装程序，打包并发布它。
How does the process of when that happens occur? And I think this is a topic of interest to a lot of people. The traditional way that it used to be done i guess almost everywhere was people would essentially write code or if you're a small team you know you will write code at some point people will begin to say oh this is we're ready to kind of build this and ship it you'll kind of compile it all package it up install it on a few computers virtual box make sure it works and then when it does you'll kind of ship it to someone and then you'll probably freeze that code and then you know start kind of
这个过程是如何发生的？我认为这对很多人来说是一个感兴趣的话题。过去几乎到处都在使用的传统方式是，人们基本上会编写代码，或者如果你是一个小团队，你会编写代码，在某个时候人们会开始说：“哦，我们准备好构建并发布它了。”你会把它全部编译、打包、安装在几台电脑上，用VirtualBox确保它能工作，然后当它能工作时，你会把它发布给某人，然后你可能会冻结那个代码，然后……
making changes against it and if there's a problem that your customer has or your friends have you would edit that frozen version and try to like apply bug fixes and that that that's kind of a very traditional way of deploying software and the software process then nowadays you start to hear a lot of talk about continuous delivery or continuous deployment we'll talk about the difference in a second and this is more once i integrate code into the repository a series of automated steps begins to occur where it builds my code, it runs my unit tests, it builds the installer, it, you know, maybe run some integration level tests, checks for problems. And that happens in a system and you'll hear stuff like Jenkins,
开始针对它进行修改。如果你的客户或朋友遇到问题，你会编辑那个冻结的版本，并尝试应用错误修复。那是一种非常传统的部署软件和软件流程的方式。现在你开始听到很多关于持续交付或持续部署的讨论（我们稍后会谈论区别）。这更多的是，一旦我将代码集成到存储库中，一系列自动化步骤就开始发生，它构建我的代码，运行我的单元测试，构建安装程序，它……也许运行一些集成级别的测试，检查问题。这发生在一个系统中，你会听到像Jenkins这样的东西，
which is what will kind of monitor for those events and perform some scripted set of actions. And continuous delivery is about doing that on a very regular basis, like every night or day, or even with every change, doing some set of those tests and integration and making sure that the code is ready to be deployed at any point. Any code you have, it always builds,
它会监控这些事件并执行一组脚本化的操作。持续交付是指在非常规律的基础上这样做，比如每天晚上或每天，甚至每次更改时，执行那组测试和集成，并确保代码在任何时候都准备好部署。你拥有的任何代码，它总是能构建，
it always is ready it's passes all the tests but then it might go through a step of like human qa or evaluation quality assurance or evaluation or testing before it's kind of promoted to this is a good release or a release candidate but you still have kind of you might hear like nightly or different people have different words for it but you'll have still installers or versions of the executable for a much more granular fine grain uh thing yeah and that that this is uh this is one of the things that makes this possible is um you know thrift and protocol buffers and these kind of like very backwards compatible information kind of representation. Like if you have so many different versions,
它总是准备好，通过了所有测试，但它可能会经过一个人类QA或评估、质量保证或测试的步骤，然后才被提升为“这是一个好的发布版本”或“发布候选版本”。但你仍然会有……你可能会听到“每晚构建”或不同的人有不同的说法，但你仍然会有安装程序或可执行文件的版本，用于更细粒度的东西。是的，这……这是使之成为可能的事情之一，是……你知道，Thrift和Protocol Buffers，这些非常向后兼容的信息表示方式。如果你有这么多不同的版本，
if you're literally putting out a new version every night and you're sort of tweaking the way that data is saved, you need something like Thrift or protocol buffers. So someone on version 800 can migrate to version 802 without having to start from scratch. That's right. And you begin to see there might be some problems, which is how do you check code into the code base for people to be able to review, but you don't want it kind of running yet, or it's incompatible with some other version. And this is where you start having feature flags come in. So portions of your code are active or not active. And then for continuous deployment is like another step above continuous delivery, where in continuous deployment, you really are, after all of the automated steps complete,
如果你真的每天晚上都发布一个新版本，并且你在调整数据保存的方式，你需要像Thrift或Protocol Buffers这样的东西。这样版本800的人就可以迁移到版本802，而不必从头开始。没错。你开始看到可能会有一些问题，比如你如何将代码签入代码库供人们审查，但你还不想让它运行，或者它与某个其他版本不兼容。这就是功能标志（feature flags）出现的地方。所以你的部分代码是激活的或未激活的。然后对于持续部署，就像是持续交付之上的另一个步骤，在持续部署中，你确实在所有自动化步骤完成后，
you're kind of saying to other people who would use your code, you can now use this. You wouldn't really, I guess, see that in something shipping to consumers. I would think that would be really weird. But for teams where you're producing a library that another team in your company consumes, they may have this where, you know, every night, there's a new version of your library produced, and their build system just picks that up into theirs. And so you better make sure that your code, and you have the tests and the automation to check that every single one of your changes could have that happen to it, because you don't know when it's going to be created at any time. Yeah, actually, it made me think of something kind of interesting.
你是在对其他使用你代码的人说：你现在可以使用这个了。我想你不会在发布给消费者的产品中看到这一点。我觉得那会很奇怪。但对于那些你生产一个库，公司里的另一个团队消费它的团队来说，他们可能有这种情况，你知道，每天晚上都会产生一个新版本的库，他们的构建系统就会把那个版本拾取到他们的系统中。所以你最好确保你的代码，并且你有测试和自动化来检查你的每一个更改都可能发生这种情况，因为你不知道它会在什么时候被创建。是的，其实这让我想起了一些有趣的事情。
I wonder how many, I wonder for an average software, for average company that develops software, how much of the software you think is used internally? My guess is a lot. I mean, my guess is probably 50% when you include it and and everything so so more than half of the software you write or your company writes will be consumed only by your company well i guess it's hard so if you talk about like a micro services architecture even just a regular distributed system you know you might have the amazon front page or home or search page or whatever there's a whole bunch of services that are behind the application that is really kind of driving most of that are
我想知道有多少……我想知道对于一家开发软件的普通公司来说，你认为有多少软件是在内部使用的？我的猜测是很多。我的意思是，我的猜测可能是50%，当你把它包括在内时……所以你编写的软件中有一半以上，或者你公司编写的软件中有一半以上，将仅由你们公司内部消费。好吧，我想这很难。如果你谈论像微服务架构，甚至只是一个常规的分布式系统，你知道，你可能有亚马逊的主页或主页或搜索页面或任何东西，在应用程序背后有一大堆服务，它们确实在驱动大部分……
those things internal or not like it's hard to say oh good point i guess internal is a little fuzzy i guess internal means the binary doesn't leave your servers oh okay but then like every website is internal only that's right that's true what we're talking about a second but i do want to say that uh you know for like microservice i said library but also if you're running a service you could redeploy that service with every code change or every night um and make sure that you're always on the freshest release. That's right. Yeah. I mean, one thing maybe people don't know unless they do web development or just this
那些东西是内部的还是不是？很难说。哦，好观点。我想“内部”有点模糊。我想内部意味着二进制文件不会离开你们的服务器。哦，好吧，但那样的话，每个网站都只是内部的。没错，那是真的。我们刚才谈论的是……但我想说的是，对于像微服务，我说的是库，但如果你在运行一个服务，你可以随着每次代码更改或每天晚上重新部署该服务，并确保你总是处于最新的版本。没错。是的，我的意思是，有一件事也许人们不知道，除非他们做Web开发或只是这种……
kind of like service-based architecture is it's designed to be very, very modular. And so, for example, if you're making like a funny meme site that has like the funniest memes and people can comment about memes, things like that, you might have a service like a funny meme site that has like the funniest memes and people can comment about memes, things like that. You might have a service that all it does is write the meme text onto the image. And it's just standalone. It's maybe in a Docker container or something. And so that team, you don't want to have this monolithic binary
基于服务的架构，它是设计成非常非常模块化的。所以，例如，如果你在做一个有趣的模因网站，上面有最有趣的模因，人们可以评论模因之类的，你可能会有一个服务……它所做的只是把模因文字写在图片上。它是独立的。它可能在一个Docker容器里之类的。所以那个团队，你不想有这种单体二进制文件。
where if anything is wrong with any part of it, nobody can ship their updates. So the team that's doing the write the text onto the image, they're doing continuous deployment and they are, you know, with some degree of certainty, like failing, you know, maybe once a year they blow up the build or something, but it's okay because there's redundancy and we'll talk about that more later. But yeah, I mean, failing you know maybe once a year they blow up the build or something but it's okay um because there's redundancy and we'll talk about that more later but yeah i mean imagine you when you build something for school you usually build this one huge binary um it's got like your project and maybe you keep adding on to it throughout the year but uh but in industry there's there's just
如果其中任何部分出了问题，没人能发布更新。所以负责将文字写入图像的团队，他们正在进行持续部署，并且他们，你知道，有一定程度的确定性，比如可能一年搞砸一次构建之类的，但这没关系，因为有冗余，我们稍后会详细讨论。但是，是的，我的意思是，想象一下当你为学校构建东西时，你通常会构建一个巨大的二进制文件，它包含了你的项目，也许你整年都在不断添加内容，但在工业界，只有
thousands and thousands of services well depending on the size of your company. But there's many, many services. And they're all kind of communicating to each other and all updating, you know, almost at least nightly, if not more often. Or at least not in a coordinated way. What's that? Yeah. There isn't a coordinated, okay, everybody roll out now. Exactly.
成千上万的服务，这取决于你公司的大小。但确实有很多很多服务。它们都在某种程度上相互通信，并且几乎每天都在更新，如果不是更频繁的话。或者至少不是以协调的方式。你说什么？是的。没有一个协调的，好吧，大家现在一起发布。没错。
Yeah. So, yeah, we could jump into web development. So maybe the first thing I'll talk about is sort of how do you update the website? And then I'll go into, you know, the database. So, you know, the database is just a recap database that holds all of your information. You know, if you're doing this meme website, the database is holding all of those images and your user accounts and all of that stuff. And then the website is where all of your logic is, which says it'll hold some data, but it's meant to be very transient. Someone uploads a new meme. It has to go somewhere.
是的。所以，我们可以进入网页开发的话题。也许我首先要谈的是你如何更新网站？然后我会深入探讨数据库。数据库只是一个保存你所有信息的汇总数据库。如果你在做一个表情包网站，数据库里存着所有的图片、用户账户以及所有这些东西。而网站则是所有逻辑所在的地方，它会保存一些数据，但它应该是非常短暂的。有人上传了一个新表情包，它必须去某个地方。
It doesn't go straight to the database. So actually, it does if you listen to last month's talk with HyperDev. But generally, you know, it goes to some web server. We're not that cool yet. It goes to some web server. That web server kind of accepts it, you know, and says, OK, this user made this meme and then puts that information in the database. So you can hot swap this. So what that means is if you have a new version, maybe that version is faster. Maybe when you upload the meme, it turns it into a JPEG or something. No matter
它不会直接进入数据库。实际上，如果你听了上个月关于 HyperDev 的讲座，它确实会。但通常情况下，它会进入某个 Web 服务器。我们还没那么酷。它会进入某个 Web 服务器。那个 Web 服务器会接收它，并说，好的，这个用户制作了这个表情包，然后把这些信息放入数据库。所以你可以热交换它。这意味着如果你有一个新版本，也许那个版本更快。也许当你上传表情包时，它会把它转换成 JPEG 之类的。无论
how you uploaded it, you could upload a PNG, it turns into a JPEG. So you want to make this change. Well, the database doesn't have to change. It's just storing these images. So what you can do is you might have the most popular meme site ever. So you have thousands and thousands of machines and they're all just super busy making your website work. So you can say, I'm going to change one of these machines to do this JPEG conversion thing and then you can actually see, you know, if you have the right logging infrastructure you can see like okay I have more JPEGs now than I did yesterday and this machine is pretty much a JPEG
你怎么上传的，你可以上传 PNG，它会变成 JPEG。所以你想做出这个改变。好吧，数据库不需要改变。它只是存储这些图像。所以你可以做的是，你可能拥有有史以来最受欢迎的表情包网站。所以你有成千上万台机器，它们都非常忙碌地让你的网站运行。所以你可以说，我要改变其中一台机器来做这个 JPEG 转换的事情，然后你实际上可以看到，如果你有正确的日志基础设施，你可以看到，好的，我现在拥有的 JPEG 比昨天多，而且这台机器基本上是一个 JPEG
and it's sane and everything. And then you say okay I've done one machine and it looks good let's do ten machines next day next day let's do 100 machines okay let's do all thousand machines and so in this way you're kind of transitioning people from one version of your site to the other another thing you can do which is what Patrick mentioned is if
而且它很正常，一切都好。然后你说，好的，我已经完成了一台机器，看起来不错，明天让我们做十台机器，后天让我们做 100 台机器，好的，让我们做所有一千台机器，通过这种方式，你正在引导人们从网站的一个版本过渡到另一个版本。你可以做的另一件事，也就是 Patrick 提到的，是如果
you might have a flag which will change all the machines at once or maybe some of the machines but it's controlled at runtime so instead of you saying I'm going to replace the code in this machine and not the other ones you say I'm going to replace the code in all the machines but only the ones that have this flag set will do something different. The rest of the machines will all continue doing the same thing they were doing before. So you're kind of trusting yourself to use those flags appropriately and not actually change something on all the machines.
你可能有一个标志，可以一次性改变所有机器，或者可能只改变部分机器，但它是在运行时控制的。所以你不是说我要替换这台机器上的代码而不是其他机器，而是说我要替换所有机器上的代码，但只有设置了此标志的机器才会做不同的事情。其余的机器将继续做它们之前所做的事情。所以你是在信任自己能适当地使用这些标志，而不是真的改变所有机器上的东西。
And that flag approach is what you have to do if you need to change the database. So let's say I'm storing these memes and my site's getting so popular that I actually have to use a new database that can only hold JPEGs, but it can do an amazing job and it will save my company a whole bunch of money because of the way it handles the JPEG. So you keep the old database around and you start bringing up the new database and you actually do duplicate writes. So in other words you say I'm going to write you know the PNG file to the old database and I'm going
如果你需要更改数据库，就必须使用这种标志方法。假设我正在存储这些表情包，我的网站变得非常受欢迎，以至于我实际上必须使用一个只能容纳 JPEG 的新数据库，但它能做得非常出色，并且由于它处理 JPEG 的方式，它将为我的公司节省一大笔钱。所以你保留旧数据库，开始启动新数据库，并实际进行重复写入。换句话说，你说我要把 PNG 文件写入旧数据库，我要
to write the JPEG file to the new database but when I read I'm going to read from the old database. And then you start monitoring and what you should hope is that these databases start to look the same over time. That, you know, eventually they should have the same data in them. And when that happens then you start having machines start reading from the new database. Like, okay, I'm writing everything twice and I'm verifying that when I write twice, they're in both databases and it looks solid. Let's have a few machines start reading from the new one. And then you keep monitoring. And then when that looks good,
把 JPEG 文件写入新数据库，但当我读取时，我将从旧数据库读取。然后你开始监控，你应该希望这些数据库随着时间的推移看起来是一样的。最终它们应该拥有相同的数据。当这种情况发生时，你就开始让机器从新数据库读取。就像，好的，我正在写两次所有内容，并且我正在验证当我写两次时，它们都在两个数据库中，看起来很稳固。让我们让几台机器开始从新数据库读取。然后你继续监控。当看起来不错时，
then you kind of switch everyone over. So it's this very gradual process, but as a person who's using the website, it's completely opaque to you. I mean, it's kind of remarkable that, you know, you could have an Amazon page and then leave it on your browser, refresh three days later. And you're probably looking at like the code that's servicing your page is completely different, but they make it look exactly the same, which is pretty awesome. Well, I think that's all we got for deploying software that was kind of three vaguely related discussions yeah i mean and this should kind of tell people uh you know it's hard it's domain specific it's not a science um um there's there's a lot of nuance a lot of cruft that's developed over the years and it's become this sort of craft there are some people who are like, you know, deployment craftsmen.
然后你把每个人都切换过来。所以这是一个非常渐进的过程，但作为一个使用网站的人，这对你来说是完全不透明的。我的意思是，这很了不起，你可以打开一个亚马逊页面，然后把它留在浏览器里，三天后再刷新。你看到的可能就是完全不同的服务于你的页面的代码，但他们让它看起来完全一样，这非常棒。好吧，我想这就是我们关于部署软件的所有内容，那是三个有点相关的讨论。是的，我的意思是，这应该告诉人们，这很难，它是特定于领域的，它不是一门科学，有很多细微差别，多年来积累了很多陈旧的东西，它已经变成了一种手艺，有些人就像是部署工匠。
What, what did we call them? Oh, I don't like when people say it's an art, but I think that's good. I'm going to use that. It's a craft. Yeah. Like we have a production engineers, um, where I work and, and, uh, um, they do more than this, but this is one of their expertise. Yeah. Craft. I'm going to use that. They do more than this, but this is one of their expertise. Yeah, a craft. They craft an installer that actually installs correctly. So just to repeat, to sort of recap, the tools of the show were Termitor and MotionStills.
我们叫他们什么来着？哦，我不喜欢人们说这是一种艺术，但我认为这很好。我要用这个词。这是一种手艺。是的。就像我工作的地方有生产工程师，他们做的不仅仅是这些，但这是他们的专长之一。是的，手艺。我要用这个词。他们做的不仅仅是这些，但这是他们的专长之一。是的，一种手艺。他们精心制作一个能正确安装的安装程序。所以重复一下，总结一下，本节目的工具是 Termitor 和 MotionStills。
The books of the show were Bayesian Methods for hackers and zero to one by peter thiel um you can check it out on our show notes get links to all of that which are on facebook apparently and on programmingthrowdown.com that's right we're on facebook someone asked me to start posting them on that's right patrick is are you boycotting actively or are you just no i think i do have an account i just i don't know i'm not a social person i'm a terrible human being so i'm not a social person so i don't find interest i i think did i talk about this last episode i checked out instagram and it was like no i don't read the comments i just look at the pictures and i'm like oh i can get behind this it's like pictures from people i think but like no words right i don't like to, like people say things and I'm just, it makes me mad or frustrated or,
本节目的书籍是《贝叶斯方法：黑客指南》和彼得·蒂尔的《从0到1》。你可以在我们的节目笔记中查看，获取所有这些链接，这些链接显然在 Facebook 上，也在 programmingthrowdown.com 上。没错，我们在 Facebook 上。有人让我开始在上面发布。没错，Patrick，你是在积极抵制还是只是……不，我想我确实有一个账户，我只是不知道，我不是一个社交型的人，我是一个糟糕的人，所以我不是一个社交型的人，所以我没有兴趣。我想我在上一集谈过这个吗？我查看了 Instagram，就像，不，我不读评论，我只是看图片，然后我想，哦，我可以支持这个，就像人们的图片，我想，但没有文字，对吧？我不喜欢，人们说些什么，我只是，这让我生气或沮丧，或者
you know, anyways. Yeah. No, I don't do Facebook. Not just Facebook, but, you know, if we're on Facebook, we're on Twitter, we're on G+, and we're on LinkedIn. Someone asked me to start posting them on LinkedIn. So I said, sure. And some people actually respond on LinkedInin which is kind of cool um uh it's a little sad that there isn't
你知道，总之。是的。不，我不玩 Facebook。不仅仅是 Facebook，但如果我们出现在 Facebook 上，我们也会出现在 Twitter、G+ 和 LinkedIn 上。有人让我开始在 LinkedIn 上发布它们。所以我说，没问题。有些人确实在 LinkedIn 上回应，这很酷。有点遗憾的是没有
one continuous thread of comments that go across all of these networks uh it's almost like like every time i add a network it kind of fragments but i think it actually doesn't fragment it just grows the amount of communication but i just wish that someone there's a startup to take that from zero to one that's right let's get peter theil on this um so you know hey check follow us on all of them then you can see all the discussions going on in parallel maybe a human can like copy all of the comments across and keep them all in sync yeah no don't don't that just sounds miserable no oh yeah definitely don't uh don't volunteer yourself for that that sounds terrible well thank you all for during another episode yeah thanks a lot um uh let me
一个跨越所有这些网络的连续评论线程。这几乎就像每次我添加一个网络，它就会碎片化，但我认为它实际上并没有碎片化，它只是增加了交流量，但我只是希望有人能有一个创业公司来把那个从 0 做到 1。没错，让我们让彼得·蒂尔来做这个。所以，嘿，关注我们所有的平台，然后你可以看到所有正在进行的讨论。也许人类可以复制所有的评论并保持它们同步。是的，不，别那样做，那听起来很痛苦。不，哦，是的，绝对不要自愿做那个，那听起来太糟糕了。好吧，谢谢大家收听另一集。是的，非常感谢。让我
know about the t-shirts um we have a straw poll vote and send us an email with your name and what t-shirt you want and if we get enough orders we will put in the bulk order I think we need 25 we'll put in the bulk order and I'm
知道关于 T 恤的事。我们有一个民意调查投票，给我们发一封电子邮件，写上你的名字和你想要的 T 恤，如果我们收到足够的订单，我们将进行批量订购。我想我们需要 25 个，我们会进行批量订购，而且我
sure we're going to get 25 but definitely let us know so that we can get you a shirt well there's you and me and our moms so we got that's right we got four 21 slots left that's right till next time see you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 our pilot. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
确信我们会得到 25 个，但一定要让我们知道，这样我们才能给你一件衬衫。好吧，有你和我，还有我们的妈妈，所以我们有……没错，我们还有 21 个名额。没错，下次见，回头见。片头音乐是 Biner Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。